cher journal aujourd'hui c'est mon
anniversaire
et comme je sais que personne ne le fera
pour moi je me suis organisé une fête
surprise chez moi quelle mauvaise idée
j'ai passé la journée à nettoyer ce qui
était déjà propre et à répéter sans
arrêt non mais t'inquiète un nom target
aux personnes qui me faisait faux bond
au dernier moment
baba bon ciné alors si j'ai mis un petit
peu de bordel pour paraître désinvolte
et m'excuser pour le bordel désolé pour
le bordel j'ai pas du tout le temps de
faire quoi que ce soit à quatre comme
commentaire je trouve que c'est le
bordel à nantes 1-4
j'enlève mes chaussures ou pas du coup
annonce inquiète tu y as tu veux mettre
ta veste est tous dans la chambre c'est
le bordel montrent inquiets
ensuite j'ai fait semblant d'être
surprise par le gâteau d'anniversaire
que j'avais moi même préparé puis j'ai
attendu qu'il termine de chanter j'ai
fait semblant d'être contente de mon
cadeau et away
alors bas pour le coup j'ai attendu
qu'il se remette à parler pour vous
pouvez parler sinon davantage d'aller au
soir et des autres c'est qu'on peut
partir quand on veut là j'ai eu envie de
rentrer chez moi à 22 heures pour
retrouver mon chien mais j'étais déjà
chez moi et puis il était déjà là alors
petit rappel pour toutes les prochaines
fois toujours pensé à organiser les
choses en semaine on samedi soir
personne ne croit que je dois bosser
tout le lendemain bon le reste de la
semaine non plus ceci dit faudrait
peut-être que je me mette à travailler
au moins ça me donnerait une bonne
excuse pour [ __ ] tout le monde dehors
pas vous n'êtes pas fatigué non non
c'était pas fatigué je vais je vais pas
tarder à me coucher
vous vous rendrez pas restée là bas on
va claquer la porte en partant je pense
s'adresse
sa tombe est parti non non non non
t'inquiète pas ce que tu vois moi je le
sens
un changement au moins